how do you feel like being a California
resident that's what I was leading up to
oh
I um
I never well where were you before I was
a California so we're just getting an
update on something that's old
Joe Joe did his research as always Joe
did his research how do you feel being a
dude now man
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of careful boys where we are off the
Record
what is that it's a kinch's move hey I
got a rats turn the kit is this a good
quality one
uh it's uh you want to get a cat
tourniquet but that works too oh rats
get chased by cats so that's why this is
the difference we got Jason chain with
us today by the way hey what's up Jason
welcome back to Jason people love you
good to finally nice to meet you Stephen
thank you guys for having me thank you
you're welcome how do you feel how do
you feel about
um most of your fan base now like JK
fans like how we helped boost your
career like crazy dude you're freaking
awesome see the nice things they said
about you and our Discord by the way
really what do they say they love you I
don't know what it oh oh I saw it on you
on Instagram that's so nice that is
really nice
you're a certified hit Jaron case Q said
everyone needs to watch Jason Cheney
stand up he's hilarious I want to see
Jason Cheney he's never seen my stand-up
he goes yo your stand is hilarious dude
yo I can't wait to see Jason perform at
Zanies in Nashville already bought my
tickets
every time there's like JK people that
come they're always so nice can you
maybe give a message to the fans yeah
hey guys I'm Jason
thank you for
thank you for watching Jake oh no cut
this cut this cut
the heartfelt I was building it up okay
I'm
like no but I yeah you know it's just
really nice cool everybody's really nice
are you ever sad because you're such a
hit but then you're a married man you
can't be [__] on the fans
I just no I just want to um you're not
that horny huh I'm not that horny
honestly I never took him as a horny guy
all right yeah I guess I guess I would
like to be more horny but I'm not a
because I want to [__] my wife a lot you
know but because I'm not that horny
do you come fast some days I do but when
I'm like on the days that I'm not
um horny then I come slow it comes slow
like it comes out slowly yeah like
toothpaste so so like every
um one million milligram every minute so
so you don't you barely notice milligram
a minute you come while you're having
sex it doesn't all come out at the end
it's not even pre-cum dude it's full
come full calm the whole sometimes you
could come a little bit uh and then if
you stop yourself hard enough then you
could you know have a big orgasm at the
end oh okay I remember the technique I
yeah I don't think I can know how that
dude is that not like a tantric method
of some sort I think if that's coming
it's coming what does tantric mean hey
that's romantic that's romantic
you know what I've been watching these
days that's pretty sick pornography um
hardcore porn so I'm really happy that
California's starting to finally relieve
itself from the drought because it's
been raining a lot and you know I love
I'm a big fan of natural disasters right
so it's been what's your top three
natural disasters I think well I mean
watching typhoons are hilarious
especially the typhoons in Asia
because when people are like holding on
to polls and then like oh my God are you
really saying this things are like
flying
okay I got it I got a handful though
because he put me on to it's people
climbing on top of their cars where it's
like what but when it's all like [__]
flooded and [__] and there's something
hilarious about it it's really weird he
put me onto when the lava goes down the
streets and it just starts melting cars
instantly and people are trying to run
away
there is something so I watched the
video recently right of this lady and
she's just like driving in like I don't
know she's like driving a Tesla and it's
probably like knee-deep water yeah and
like these people are standing outside
like what the [__] are you doing this
just keeps going and then all of a
sudden they're both just like it just
turns into a boat it just starts [__]
floating right and then she like starts
turning around and you could just see
her go from the moment of like why is
everyone [__] stay here it's [__]
stupid it's a little bit of water oh
[__] oh [__] [__] but then because
Teslas don't have engines
she [__] managed to get to a surface
a little apart and drives right clean
out like a hovercraft unbelievable like
a duck boat yeah it was great it was
great and I I just been because your
engine won't get flooded and this video
is sponsored by Tesla there you go I
just I just been checking out you know
how the status of our water water levels
are doing I mean I'm not a Californian
anymore but you know as a person from
afar that has roots in California I'll
was like how was our reservoirs doing
and a lot of them they're doing better
than what they who are you asking this
sounds like a guy who got caught
watching before he's like oh no no I was
just looking at California
I was like the California rest so like
yeah I have roots in California so I
gotta check the reservoir situation dude
he's caught typing soaking wet
reservoirs
they're wet I actually read Playboy for
the Articles it's not really I
understand it's not for the he gets good
Tech advice there yeah that's great I do
it for the articles are a little
intellectual man yeah I'm glad you have
a passion for something like floods
how do you feel like being a California
resident that's what I was leading up to
oh
I um
I never well where were you before I was
a California oh have you only have you
only been so we're just getting an
update on something that's old
Joe did his research as always Joe did
his research so how do you feel how do
you feel being a dude now man
what's it like being a comedian now man
big change of career
is it awkward I felt so pressured when
you asked me to go I was like I don't
know what to say he just went with it
yeah I wanted to say something but I was
like I don't know I mean like as a
Californian right yeah I'm assuming that
you have a lot of like I mean you care
about your state
and it's in a drought it's been in the
drought for such a long time don't
Reservoir shame him dude
I'm just saying is why is the out of
state or caring more about the drought
situation than a Californian hmm that's
all I'm saying just double it down on
back him up that he's not watching porn
right now
it's like why are you
Jason Jenny do you find this room to be
welcoming
uh and or or because sometimes I always
get worried about new people coming in
because we already have like a group
right but then I get worried that maybe
people are going to be like intimidated
because we have a Vibe and like maybe
they're coming into it how what's your
cold take on this just as a as you're a
comedian so you can you know you'll be
honest that's really nice that you you
said that that you asked that but today
I just felt because I I went through it
I was like oh man like you guys do have
a thing and then sometimes I feel left
out by a lot of the times you guys will
be like oh you say some stuff and then I
get to say some stuff yeah yeah which is
really nice well no we try to bring you
in is what you're saying right yeah you
guys yeah really nice and um but now I'm
just like oh they're just you know our
friends and they're just saying stuff
and sometimes I want to say stuff and
I'll say stuff and sometimes I don't say
do you know how videos work
um I'm learning I'm learning as we do
this yeah yeah so no but I don't but
you're just nice and sometimes I'll say
a thing and sometimes I don't say a
thing yeah but it's just feels like I
know but I'm just saying it twice
reiterating it so so you get the point
because he knows he's talking to a
[__] dancer no I'm just saying he's
saying I'm just saying something is this
your third or fourth time here
um I think he's either third or fourth
no because because this is first because
this is the first time you guys me so
that means every single time yeah
because I know I missed missed one when
you were here yeah that's that but most
of the wow you remember
yeah I remember he also asked you if
it's your third four he didn't remember
that oh yeah yeah cause I know I missed
once but then that that that's just what
that's all I was like mind-blowing like
oh wait this is your first time with
Steve yeah that blew my mind too because
I was uh yeah I was looking forward so
he's been here months before everybody's
in the comments have been saying Jason's
the new Steve it's pretty safe
everybody's been saying that that's big
they're nothing alike don't be racist
yeah I don't know what that means be
careful but um yeah that's uh hey say
something I'm waiting for you to say
you're saying something so I'm not going
to say something when you're saying
something do you know how videos work
yeah he's being welcoming you are one of
the most requested people to have back
in terms of like fans saying stuff
they're always like when's Jason coming
back bring Jason back yeah they don't
ask about other people but they ask
about you no that's not true they asked
about everybody and that's really nice
you know not really not everybody yeah
not everybody and not not anyone as
often as they ask about you really yeah
that you can check for yourself in
comments like people are always like
it's not nothing to do with you on the
video and they're like when's Jason
coming back wow that is that is really
really nice but also it's even nice that
uh yeah sometimes I just wanna
be um good on the with the group too but
sometimes I'm just like man I don't know
how to be good with the group and I'm
just gonna do I'm just gonna
have a good time yeah that's it just
jump in yeah I just try to have a good
time you're already on the on the
wavelength say the word gay sometimes
and think that that's crazy and it'd be
fine do you do you read our comments
yeah
yeah does it hurt your feelings
sometimes okay well what was the comment
that hurts your feelings I don't know I
just went with it just now oh you just
agreed just to agree when's the last
time you got your feelings hurt yeah
um yes two days ago what I was doing is
I was doing a set and
um
and I just wasn't locked in with like
yeah sometimes my feelings are hurt
uh all the time but I just get you know
I just sometimes it hurts and I go ah
it's fine how do you get over it I just
go like this ah it's fine you literally
tell yourself that in your head you go
or you say it out loud you just said how
we got it when you say not locked in
were you doing new material and you were
delivering it the right way like it was
hitting before it's just not hitting
tonight or were you not or you're doing
old material what was going on yeah just
a bunch of bunch of um stuff okay like
for example like for example one of this
stuff was like if I if I say a new
material thing and then did it and then
if the um if the room energy wasn't good
is not good because the energy is
everything I feel like yeah if the
energy is good everything is good yeah
like even if it's not handed but we're
having a good time but you know a lot of
the times some shows it's like they come
out you know your friend dragged you out
you know and they go come let's go watch
a thing and then defense is like [__] I
don't want to go watch your thing but I
like every time I go to your house you
give me free cheese than wine so I'll go
with you to this [__] yeah and then
they come and they're like [__] man I
don't want to see this [__] and then
it's me pulling my heart out yeah and
then you see their face like can you see
who those people are yeah because
they're looking at their [__] hands
and I'm telling my [__] best jokes
and then they're going like this they're
like look at my finger why is it here
and then I go oh [__] my oh [__] my
feelings well but what it but how do you
know they're not like me where I'm
listening but I'm not like looking like
I'm listening
because it's just like you'd see it in
their eyes do you watch something and
you're having a legitimately amazing
time but you're just not showing it yep
and sometimes I look engaged like a
[__] but I'm not there
did me and Nikki do that because because
like uh my wife my wife and I do this
thing where we'll watch something and if
we both think it's funny we're like Ah
that's funny but we don't necessarily
laugh all the time it's weird they go
you mean it's like when you're texting
lol but you don't actually it's like
that's like a writer's laugh yeah yeah
but you have to also let them know that
it's funny though you laughed on the you
feel funny like on the inside yeah
exactly if you get the you get the the
little like the little oh yeah that was
funny I like that yeah but we don't
necessarily laugh every time we
sometimes just go oh that was funny
mental checklist yeah yeah like
acknowledgment I always laugh extra hard
at a comedy show even when I don't feel
like it for respect because I know what
it's like to be a comedian even though I
never did doing charity left it's called
charity no I have to though because
sometimes I'm in the improv group
watches itself yes dude and there's more
of them in the audience than on the
stage oh and you just know you just know
that it's required attendees because
they're in the class but the reviews are
in the reviews are in I can't deny hot
show man because things are funny like
like you said they're funny right you
feel it and you're like oh that was
funny but then it takes so much energy
to go
it doesn't always hit it doesn't always
hit like a laugh but it's like oh that
was funny that's true you know what I
enjoy I enjoy what I'm not necessarily
in the mood to laugh so I'm not really
laughing at something that's like
comedic but then when they do hit a joke
and it makes me laugh like it forces out
of me then I'm like that's really really
funny and that feels really good that
doesn't feel really good right yeah I
like those moments too almost when it's
for some stupid reason it's almost like
guilty will happen it's like oh yeah
that's oh [__] because your mood is in
like super exciting because you're not
always like like when I put on like a
Netflix special it doesn't mean I'm
always like I'm ready to laugh you know
what I mean yeah but something will be
said you just bust up out of nowhere you
weren't thinking you're gonna laugh like
I did this the other day watching Andrew
Schultz with uh with Nina and there are
certain things where maybe it's because
I almost felt guilty because he was just
dunking on the WNBA and stuff like that
but I was sitting next to Nina so it's
extra fun why would you feel guilty
about that in here it's different in
here the way you guys dunk on all the
time I'm secondary laughing because you
guys are already laughing what are we
dunking on the WNBA you don't do the
same thing I do if there's someone
smashing on WNBA I go hey defend them
the fandom what do you have to say and
they and she usually they can't defend
them so she's on my side now we're both
done you toss her in yeah you're
Advanced hey you're fine you're Defender
can you do it Nina let's see me and
Nikki were driving into Vegas a month
and a half ago right from Christmas
[__] right
and we get into Vegas and Nikki's like
so we see a sign and it says like
congratulations to you know the the
winners we won the Championships and
then Nikki goes holy [__] the I guess
Vegas WNBA they won the championship and
I was like you didn't know that that is
why everyone doesn't care about the WNBA
you're a woman you you didn't even know
that I knew that she doesn't even know
that one big roast that I saw oh that's
pretty [__] tight I wish I remembered
her name but she's one of the star
players on the Vegas WNBA team and uh
one basketball player was roasting the
WNBA and then she claped back with if
you guys win a championship I'll listen
to you talk because she actually won one
I was like oh [__] and I think that
they're probably like I could probably
win a WNBA Championship on my own
just like me like no other players they
should do on a man then they shouldn't
hey what's your what kind of hobbies you
got brother
um I like to smoke cigars oh no [__]
yeah you like a Monte Cristo I know you
like a Gurkha no it's they're expensive
really yeah what do you do like black
your mouth or sort of [__] do you have a
human door
as yeah but it's like a just like a
cookie jar okay yeah but those are yeah
the cookie jars are the best that's cool
yeah
um
you have a humidor I tried it
I do Joe that's a weird question you
just met the guy
too personal yeah it's really personal I
I try to find like a lot of hobbies so I
like a one time I like flew kites
oh yeah I've like height and um he likes
kites do you like kites I like kite you
need to teach me I have a professional
one I still can't even fly that [__] you
mean the ones with two handles we gotta
sit down and [__] go crazy I don't
know I bought it from REI because it
looked [__] sick and I still couldn't
even fight it was windy as [__] Bart
would get the one that takes the muscle
work to do no but it was a it's like one
of those sick ass ones and then I was
like tiger like Papa will show you how
to do this he's like I don't think you
know how to do this I'm like trust me I
do there are some really difficult kites
yeah I think you need to show me you
really like kites I like kite oh one
kite yeah the only reason why this
[__] thing is popping us because I
told the kite story let's just focus on
your hobbies what else do you like to do
he likes to kite what are you talking
about he just said yeah Kyle is cool it
was a hobby thing how often do you go
kite flying kiting once every five years
I hope it [__] hits an electrical
wire yeah good don't go kiting that's
weird it sounds weird as [__] what's a
what's a more frequent hobby yeah what's
your top hobby I like to when I when I'm
on the road I like to eat
um
I like to go eat with friends
I like okay do you know what a hobby is
yeah so I like that but that's like
actually it's like building a skill or
something would you say like a foodie
kind of thing is that what you think
well I just like the food how like good
food that when you put it in your mouth
you're like that's a good one so foodie
he's a food he likes like food he likes
food yeah this is why all the fans
I'm telling you they love fish so I'm
sorry do you search for local food when
you're trying to get that feeling are
you do you look for like oh I'm in like
New Mexico this is what they're known
for I'm in Florida yeah I try to do that
I do try to do that and then
um yeah everywhere I go I try to find
like one or two places so you do the
research in preparation I just Yelp and
then I go what type of food I'm craving
and I just go there yeah like but
usually it would be like some
but it's pretty if you if you're in the
South or it's just good barbecue I try
to eat good barbecue I love good
barbecue yeah and always spicy yes sir
like spicy yeah I love spicy I like I
need to feel something
me too you like Sichuan food no because
it has a numbing thing oh I like that
what is that called anyway we went to
San we went literally numbing pepper
it's literally numbing spices
like Dental numbing well they use this
pepper that feels like anesthesia a
little bit you should go all right go
yeah I don't know if you'd like it but
you should try it do you love spicy but
this is a hit or miss yeah good flavor
though whatever if for real has tingles
yeah yeah when you eat the the
peppercorn like pop rocks and chips
let's go boys and then there's an act
two once you're done digesting oh yeah
dude the next day were you guys
destroying your guts yeah it was a
little bit I had a hard time oh talking
about guts I um I've been eating dates
oh yeah and date is really good for gut
health
I like I love dating I discovered dates
like dogs because you always have snacks
it's like a natural fruit roll-up that's
a good choice yeah it's a healthy snack
I just thought you were wearing a diaper
huh oh because you're crinkling all over
the [__] place when you're walking in
here I just thought you were in a diaper
I guess oh the sound of his Zips with
the no yeah I was like oh no but no
judgments expense is that what they're
called extend the pens it depends this
is a dick drug
[Laughter]
Bart knew that though
let's go let's go hey what are you
what's your what's the night with your
wife what do you guys like to do for
funds
um it's like a perfect night together a
perfect night together we are in the
hotel room
and uh away from
everybody and then just uh eat some ice
cream
you know put the
have have a little intimate adult things
you know no
condom that's always the best how come a
hotel you don't like your house what is
it it just feel like I feel like at the
house there's always something that you
have to do you know always yeah yeah
Hotel sex is very very nice sometimes
it's true it's like it's like being a
tourist somewhere else right yeah
suddenly you get to break different
rules that you normally not allow
yourself to do at home yeah it's too
familiar at home that's what I'm saying
I can't step on Nikki's head at home
just feels weird
that's domestic violence wait is that
are you stepping on Nikki's head you
guys haven't seen that before when the
guys step on the girl's head while
they're [__] doggy styling them
you guys don't watch enough porn we're
gonna watch it step on the head while
they're doggy style like you have your
leg one nugget get your yeah you got
your foot on their head
referencing this whole time what Joe's
disappointed though we haven't been
watching step on your head doggy porn I
didn't I didn't know but how did you but
if you step on somebody's head wouldn't
you be worried to have a boner you'd be
like oh [__] no it gives you a harder
burner oh okay yeah
it's like the guys that like to do
massive damage when they have sex yeah
oh you like that I'm somewhat of a
Savage they call me The Saboteur
I like sensual sex
no I mean I I like the Rampage
you guys ever play that game yes I'm
glad you got to know him a little bit
yeah good to meet you brother pleasure
honestly a pleasure
Rampage World Tour
[Music]
thank you